voici le robot Xiaomi qui s'appelle
cyber one alors cyber one il est
intéressant pourquoi parce que Xiaomi il
y a vraiment investir avec un robot
formule anoïde pour démocratiser la
robotique alors le robotique va pas
arriver maintenant le but c'est pas de
mettre un robot chez vous c'est pas du
tout le but de Xiaomi mais en fait le
but de Xiaomi c'est vraiment de venir
investir à l'avenir Xiaomi d'investir
avec beaucoup de technologie au
proposant d'énormément de capteurs alors
ce robot il va marcher quoi à 3,6 km/h
voire saisir des objets pour faire des
choses que vous vous ne ferez pas et
l'idée une fois de plus avec cette
technologie c'est de venir faciliter la
vie aux humains on peut l'emmener
également en milieu dangereux et surtout
c'est tout le travail qui est fait
derrière avec de l'intelligence
artificielle peut venir reconnaître ici
notamment 45 émotions humaines ça c'est
marrant également 85 sauts environnants
et la différents modules il peut
notamment venir reconstruire son
environnement en trois dimensions avec
un niveau de précision de 99% à 8 m
c'est énorme est-ce que vous seriez
prêts vous avoir arrivé un robot à
l'horizon 10 15 20 ans peut-être chez
vous pour faire plein de choses que vous
vous ne feriez pas est-ce que ça
pourrait vous plaire oui non quoi
comment faire vraiment intéressant
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment dans les commentaires